elle s'est penchée sur son encolure lui
a susurré quelques mots à l'oreille et
très rapidement ils leur reprise ça ça
marche là comme si de rien n'était et
évidemment ça la veille était vraiment
un incident important en 1981 et ça
c'est fait le trooping the colour de 80
c'était quelques semaines avant les
noces du prince charles avec diana
ceinture donc évidemment le seul à
augmenter la sécurité par là c'est parce
que ce soit qu'on appelle le flegme
britannique à pouvoir maîtriser comme ça
ça bien sûr et tout et tout ces émotions
ces moments qui aurait pu être très
paniquant c'est certain oui très
exactement parce que évidemment le
cheval est habitués ou au bruit de la
foule mais pas ce type de brûlures et
mais c'est ça cette monture l'a été et
elle a monté ce cheval jusqu'en 1986 et
lorsque le cheval a été rendue trop
vieux pour faire 10 p c'est à ce moment
là qu'elle a décidé que dorénavant elle
continuerait à l'est au défilé mais en
carrosse parce que c'était ça devenait
le trot
à lucy hale avance en âge et d'entraîner
un nouveau cheval c'est ça devenait le
trop compliquée et elle a décidé de
changer la façon de procéder parce que
gaston tous ces soldats ce sont vous
allez vous allez vouloir ce sont des
vrais soldats sont des militaires qui
vont sur des combats qui vont en mission
maintien paix qui vont ambitions de
surveillants et on leur demande aussi où
il s'entraîne pour être cavalli juste à
20 c ce moment là qui est important à
leur carrière
oui mais en fait de vous parler
uniquement de c'est ce qu'on appelle la
household cavalry qui est réellement
partagé par des régimes à blinder alors
ils ont ils font la rotation entre ce
cette mission protocolaire et leurs
missions opérationnelles
alors vous avez des régimes sains comme
le royal tancrède humaine et puis aussi
le
il ya au moins trois régiments sauf
erreur qui font partie de ce qu'il faut
remise des trophées finalement à la
cavalerie qui va protéger la reine cette
cavalerie là et dans toutes les
cérémonies en fait elle est passée
quotidiennement finalement la relève de
la garde et tout mais encore une fois
c'est c'est pas des des soldates
démonstration non non non non nous ont
réellement de missions particulières et
puis le blues and royals qui est un
régime à bled et qui donc qui font
partie aussi de la trilogie qui fournit
des trop bas ce moment là ils peuvent
être déployées soit en afghanistan ou
dans d'autres
mais on s'entraîne aussi pour pour cet
événement là quoi c'est au moins j'ai vu
au moins deux ou trois mois donc c'est
ça devienne emplois temps plein les
marches et tout toute l'histoire liée à
ça effectivement c'est que c'est comme
une opération militaire finalement il ya
énormément de préparation qui se fait il
ya énormément de pratique aussi qui doit
se faire de façon à ce que tout soit
impeccable parce qu'évidemment ça l'a
finalement d'une retombée mondiale
puisque ça va faire l'objet finalement
le reportage partout à travers le monde
et puis c'est quand même un événement
rare plus particulièrement cette année
parce que sa marque le 70e anniversaire
de de l'accession entre on le sait pas
si on peut aller en plein écran sur ces
images là parce que l'on commencé à voir
des membres de la famille royale ça va
nous permettre de mieux les mieux les
identifier
alors on les voit justement
c'est la refuse oui est ce qu'on trouve
les amateurs de nous de nous dire qui on
voit décembre comme ça et l'ordre dans
lequel ils ont
dans le premier carrosse on voit
crémieux la duchesse de cornouailles est
ainsi que l'inceste de knin brise et les
trois enfants
du duc de cambridge après ce genre de la
princesse charlotte il le prince lui
dans le deuxième quart au son de très
brièvement aperçu les comptes de ce sex
et là dans les autres on voit pas très
bien horreur ils ont passé un peu
rapidement mais on va peut-être aller
voir un peu plus loin dans le
roman de vulliod seulement pour 400 cc
très mal la famille streit qui
qui est décidée mais il y à il y aura
près d'autres membres de la famille qui
vont être aux fenêtres de
guider des bureaux de
vote ils vont aussi pouvoir voir
la cérémonie suivra suivent de très près
et on verra défiler comme ça des images
absolument spectaculaire j'attire votre
attention
vous me corriger si j'ai les bonnes
expressions
parce que l'on voit ici c'est une
fanfare monte alors tous ces cavaliers
joue également d'un instrument
question je vous vois regarder ça c'est
ça relève de l'exploit mais contrôler la
monture comme ça et jouer la musique en
même temps je sais fin de l'entraînement
ce n'est pas un entraînement mais c'est
la même chose aussi pour ceux qui sont
au sol parce que quelquefois et il faut
qu'ils marchent aussi ces messieurs
alors ça prend du souffle et puis il ya
quand même une musique italienne
la démonstration canada et le fonds
acura en cours à quoi est en joie de
leurs instruments alors ça prend
énormément de chauffer des bons mollets
il ya peut-être lieu de simplement
remettre en perspective aussi les de la
pop et des symboles que ça représente
c'est pas quelque chose qui est née
hier soir les légions romaines avait des
symboles chaque région légion pardon se
faisait donner finalement un aigle et
puis si la légion perdait cet aigle à l
est est déshonoré alors ça monte un peu
finalement tout ce qui est en termes de
mythologie derrière les drapeaux parce
que au début j'avais juste un mec comme
ça qui était monté soit piqué et puis
par la suite il ya eu énormément de
sophistication au niveau de leur
identification alors chaque légion avait
son numéro de légion et puis ça servait
à ce moment là justement de savoir pour
le commandant de toutes les légions sur
le terrain le savoir bon mattel légion
est encore en forme parce que je jouais
ce moment-là leurs signes ont leurs
signes légionnaires qui est encore bien
debout bien grandi et sinon basques ont
malgré ça pourrait participer aussi
comme un homme comme instrument pour
communiquer les intentions de faire
passer tel légion à gauche ou à droite
et sert alors c'était un symbole visuel
très très très très visible et ses
demeures et finalement par contre la
mythologie de si vous perdez vos
drapeaux si vous perdez votre identité à
ce moment là vous êtes déshonoré alors
ça se perpétue un quart parce qu'encore
une fois dans le passé on apportait les
drapeaux les couleurs résume en terre
sur les champs de bataille mais
maintenant cette tradition là évidemment
les champs de bataille sont beaucoup
trop
dispersée pour permettre ça parce que
c'était réel mal dans ta débattra âgées
par exemple au 19e siècle là ça va
encore toute sa signification mais
maintenant si c'est très symbolique
vous allez voir il
après sociale
les colonnades et nous
nous allons
le prince charles qui menaient tout le
monde qu'il est le colonel des welsches
board et le prince william qui est le
colonel des irish d'or dont on voit
aussi le premier bataillon l'autre qui
vont recevoir de nouvelles couleurs
aujourd'hui dans que les trois
avancées plus belle eau le défi de ses
troupes militaires bon vous parlez des
arrigans javi ce je vous pose la
question pourquoi eux cette année
j'essaie à tour de rôle il ya cinq
divisions et à tour de rôle y'a
régiment qui est mis à l'honneur
normalement il y aurait dû avoir ses
nouvelles couleurs en 2010 9 mai
dû à la fin des halles afin de mieux on
a reporté sa à cette année donc ce sont
les pays riches cornes et on peut les
reconnaître parce qu'ils ont sur
leurs bonnets à poils ils ont
une
sorte de petite touffe bleus qui est les
distingue des autres régiments et sur
leur iphone la compétition il ya quatre
boutons qui sont placés d'une façon bien
spécifique et et
aussi il ya un trèfle irlandais sur leur
colle donc ceux des petites
constructions mais qui font que on les
reconnaît par rapport aux autres groupes
clients parce qu'il sent que groupe dans
le lao a sauvé les grenadiers les goûts
suivent les riches les scot et les
voyages donc c'est c'est cette
distinction lors chacun grâce à des
marques distinctives et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les les chapeaux à
pouvoir décoller les épiciers par
les aphtes et c'est le le poil vient des
ours les femelles ours alors que pour
les soldats savez des ours les mâles
course donc c'est une petite distinction
mais c'est cet intéressant
à savoir et leurs uniformes a pris
emprunté aux grenadiers de la garde
impériale
sous napoléon 1er donc là aussi on you
c'est sûr dans ce type de de régis mal
les décorations les uniformes c'est
c'est très traditionnel ça va chercher
des significations qui remonte la
11e 15e 7 et parfois même
avant donc si c'est intéressant de voir
comment tous ces petits détails lors
font que chaque régiment sommes vraiment
des
éléments qui les distinguent les uns des
autres et ça donne aussi
pour pour monsieur tout le monde qui se
connaît pas bien évidemment sur c'est un
spectacle à grand déploiement que
tous les britanniques ont certainement
vu au moins une fois dans leur vie oui
mais je n'ai pas beaucoup qui pourrait
décrire cela comme vous laissez moi vous
dire avec la précision avec laquelle
vous avez des kids mais si je comprends
bien l'archiviste que vous êtes plein
pourrait facilement trouver le bouquin
le livre avec les espèces et les ordres
et les spécificités de toucy uniforme de
deux galas de parra ben c'est tout est
écrit tout est calculé ah oui ça oui ça
c'est certain que c'est tout est
documenté surtout maintenant on a
winter's bone ou de lire des documents
mais maintenant avec eux avec internet
c'est un guide mais relativement facile
de retrouver de retrouver ce type
d'information mais c'est c'est pour moi
c'est c'est passionnant d'aller chercher
les petits détails qui font que
chaque et c'est ça la monarchie pour
sonner pour moi c'est ce qui me fascine
c'est que il ya tellement de petits
détails c'est comme le protocole n'y a
pas de livre qui décrit mot tabou c'est
quoi le protocole celle usages alors là
c'est vraiment une question
d'interprétation
mais évidemment la coutume facture c'est
tout rond l'aide de près toujours de la
même façon mais c'est pas écrit noir sur
blanc que de l'événement ou telle
circonstance doit être identifié de
telle façon donc ça c'est pour ça que
pour plusieurs sérieux il ya plusieurs
paires il a
évolué dans ce monde là parce que il
n'ya pas le protocole est pas écrit mais
il reste qu
il ya plusieurs personnes qui peuvent
facilement aider les nouveaux puits qui
rend pas le système
dont j'entendais des commentateurs dans
les autres
défilé dans les autres années dirait ya
peu de personnes aussi compétentes que
la reine pour observer un défilé
militaire comme celui du salut aux
couleurs du de mémoire c'est exactement
comment comment ils doivent être alignés
quand ils font la marche la contremarche
par max ne dirais pas terrifiant parce
qu'on a quand même vu des combats mais
c'est quelque chose apparemment que de
2,2 de faire ce défilé devant la reine
oui et c'est pour ça aussi que c'est un
site est ce moment l'autre tout le
personnel a donné leur meilleur
performance durant ces cérémonies la
madame le bouthillier a mentionné le nom
de blues and royals il faut se rappeler
aussi c'est toujours d'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y avait quand
même eu un attentat en 1992 lors d'une
cérémonie il y avait eu deux bombes en
fait qu'ils avaient été plantés sur le
tracé de cette cérémonie là et il y
avait eu en fait des pertes autant chez
les blues and royals que celle
la musique qui étaient fournis à ce
moment là par un autre et jumale royal
green jacket et puis il y avait une
douzaine de morts à ce moment là alors
ça ça use ex-aequo si à ce moment là que
pour toutes les cérémonies l'aspect
sécurité est extrêmement important tout
au long du tracé évidemment lorsque
jusqu'à la place de rassemblement qu'on
a vu précédemment ou des troupes sur 2
janvier est ce que les militaires vous
avez côtoyé les britanniques
vous dise mais moi je les fais le
troupeau est ce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on a vu presque envie de vous dire
est ce que c'est au mérite ou est-ce
qu'on soumet une candidature pour
participer ou si on est désigné comme
on obtient cette classe dans un défilé
de 20/20 la monarque ben en fait c'est
selon les ordres de l'unité ya quand
même une rotation de ses une telle à
dévider maille en a qui vont se porter
volontaire ci est toujours un homme
personnes limitées pour assister à la
parade comme tel alors si ça prenne
encore une fois ça prenne une formation
de 150 personnes il ya 250 personnes
nous sommes dans un régime a qui vont
être identifiées
plutôt que d'avoir tout le régiment
alors c'est sûr qu'à ce moment là il y
en a qui ont de tels se porter
volontaire mais faut souligner quand
même que ces cérémonies là sont
extrêmement longues
évidemment nous on est à à l'aube mais
ils sont quand même là debout depuis
déjà une heure ou deux ouais alors
certains d'entre eux sont des plantes on
aux cantons là pour marquer le
territoire et puis il ne bouge pas
beaucoup là alors vous pouvez vous
assurer que l on m'a donné la fatigue
commence à s'installer dans les muscles
du dos et tout et tout alors il faut
bouger les utiliser pour une fierté
j'entendais des témoignages et leurs
familles les encourage ça semble être un
honneur familial également boye
effectivement c'en est un c'est un peu
moins peut-être
perceptibles ici au canada mais la bosse
allait beaucoup parce que la reine est
quand même une personnalité mythique 1
c'est quand même quelque chose de ces
deux c'est spécial parce que on oppose
rennes tous les jours
puis moi même en fait c'est pour ma par
accident que j'ai j'ai participé à une
garde cérémonial c'est que moment donné
lorsque les venues visiter le canada
menace 1 76 jours des jeux olympiques
la première étape qu'elle faisait ce
qu'il atterrissait au nouveau brunswick
puis à ce moment là on ne prie les
élèves officiers dont je faisais partie
on a fourni une garde d'honneur pour la
reine à son arrivée à l'aéroport alors
c'est c'est unique mal c'était pas un vj
bastais tous les régiments qui faisait
partie de ce cours là qui ont été mis à
contribution et se faisait pas
nécessairement partie du curriculum du
court oui on le fait que c'était une
belle sortie pour la famille royale
puisque la reine venait aux jeux
olympiques les inauguré et peut-être je
sais pas s'il est resté pour voir sa
fille la princesse anne oui pour
correction et imputations oui oui
effectivement alors justement celle des
crimes et non un peu ce que l'on voit
dans le moment ça c'est le seul à la
regarde c'est là qu'on aura lieu la
cérémonie qui sont ces gens dans les
estrades raison qu' il y en a beaucoup
qui sont particulièrement spécialement
invités pour l'événement mais il ya eu
il ya eu les gens pouvaient comme une
sorte de loterie pouvait
donnez leur don pour justement pouvoir
assister le dans les estrades ya aussi
des places payantes et
mais il ya aussi toute la foule le quai
le long le long du trajet mais c'est
toujours ces événements là c'est
toujours très couru et il ya plus de
demandes que de places alors c'est
choisir au sort qui va avoir une place
ça c'est fait le yoyo les gens ont su
déjà quelques semaines qui avaient eu la
chance de pouvoir y aller et
c'est vraiment la très très particulier
de pouvoir la
cérémonie surtout cette année vu que
c'est le 70e anniversaire
de la reine autres ont bien évidemment
salle une touche là encore plus
particulière il faut se souvenir aussi
que comme nous sommes le 2 juin c'est
aussi le 69e anniversaire de son
couronnement donc une différence
évidemment à la date de l'accession 6
février 52 et la date du couronnement le
2 juin 1953 alors c'est dany évidemment
on
souligne l'accession et je suis
convaincu que l'an prochain
il y aura aussi la fait pas autant de
déploiement mais vaut certainement avoir
des festivités pour souligner le
couronnement bon là dessus je peux vous
dire vous pouvez pratiquement juste et
vous montrera regardant les images
passent quand je dis qu'on était pour
être en position assez 00 00 et c'était
le cas tout tous les cavaliers et était
là je vais tout de suite me tourner vers
marie ève bédard qui est fait est à
londres qui suit ça de très près pour
nous derrière on n'a pas tous les jours
l'occasion de voir des dés des
cérémonies comme celle là d'abord tout
de suite côté météo disons que les
anglais disent toujours à la blague on
est habitué à l'humidité et à la petite
pluie mais tout semble être parfait de
ce côté là en tout cas jusqu'à
maintenant
jusqu'ici fait un soleil radieux
marc-andré ce qui est une très bonne
nouvelle parce que ça peut aider l'école
depuis une semaine on a eu droit des
averses de grêle depuis un temps
changeant les anglais le prennent très
bien en disant c'est ça la météo ici il
faut s'habituer même les gens qui ont
commencé à se masser sur le mal là où va
défiler ce cortège militaire pour
s'assurer d'avoir une bonne place les
gens qui n'ont pas pu acheter un billet
ont commencé à passer la nuit d'autres
sont arrivés des quatre heures dès 5h ce
matin ils ont envie de faire la fête
d'abord la météo coopèrent oui mais il
faut dire aussi que ça fait deux ans que
le climat social est très difficiles
partout sur la planète mais ici aussi
avec l'aco vide les gens ont besoin
distille de cette célébration et ils ont
besoin aussi de souligner ses 70 ans de
règne de la reine sans nous le dit c'est
du jamais vu on ne le reverra potes de
notre vivant aujourd'hui cortège
militaire c'est pour célébrer
l'anniversaire de la reine elizabeth 96
ans on s'inquiète un peu de son état de
santé les gens savent qu'elles ne sera
pas éternel et que c'est probablement la
dernière fois qu'on peut la célébrer de
cette façon on ne sait pas jusqu'à quel
point elle va prendre part aux
cérémonies aujourd'hui ça c'est la
grande question regarde on était avec
des gens tout à l'heure qui espérait
pouvoir la voir passer dans un cortège
et des carrosses qui sont passés la
rumeur s'est emparé de la foule en dix
ans elle est là et il est là finalement
il est évident c'est des bons allait se
mettre en place pour participer aux
cérémonies mais tout le monde espère
pouvoir au moins la voir aujourd'hui sur
certains d'entre eux pensent qu'elle
soit sur le balcon avec le reste de la
famille royale active plus tard dans la
journée quand ils les forces aériennes
royales la raf qui vont survoler votre
gain de place pour saluer la reine et la
foule à la fin la clôture de ces
cérémonies qui doivent commencer très
prochainement tuellement on est bien
curieux de voir qui sont ces gens
amassés le long du mall est ce que vous
pouvez me décrire est ce que ce sont des
gens est ce que ce sont des ddd
britannique plus âgé est ce qu'il ya des
touristes y at-il simplement l'a déjà
qu'ils sont là pour la fête qui qui sont
là pour profiter des quatre jours de
congé
on trouve un peu de tout marc-andré
évidemment il ya des gens qui sont de
londres il ya des gens qui sont venus
des quatre coins de la grande bretagne
pour s'assurer d'assister à ces
cérémonies même si partout au pays les
quatre prochains jours vont marquer les
commémorations de façon très importante
ces gens voulaient être là on a
rencontré plusieurs groupes canadiens
aussi des gens qui ont fait le voyage
depuis le canada et puis la nouvelle
écosse depuis le québec depuis l'alberta
la colombie-britannique aussi et qui
voulaient venir souligner le jubilé de
la reine j'ai rencontré tout à l'heure
un groupe d'allemands qui disait
regretter de ne pas avoir la monarchie
en allemagne que c'était pour elle un
peu elle ne percevait comme une religion
il faut croire à la monarchie ont-elles
dit c'était de très jeunes filles donc
vous retrouver un peu de toutes les
générations et sur certaines vous
retrouver des gens très colorés les gens
ce sont certains sont habillés de façon
très chic beaucoup de femmes qui avaient
accès aux estrades autour du roi 5 par
exemple porte la robe les talons le
chapeau traditionnel et d'autres sont
habillés aux couleurs de l'union jack le
drapeau du pays pour célébrer bon
d'écouter y en at il qui exprime la
ddc de courant
on doit mettre fin à la monarchie ceux
qui sont républicains qui disent bon là
c'est la dernière fois qu'on fait ça ça
devrait être terminée ça existe autant
au royaume-uni qu'ailleurs ici au canada
et des gens qui vont nous le dire bon
pour couper les liens faut mettre fins à
ses dépens voyez vous le voyez vous
cette expression là également dans
londres ou même là où vous vous trouvez
là près du palais de buckingham
on voit des gens qui se questionnent sur
la pertinence de garder la monarchie
surtout après le règne de la reine
elizabeth qui a été un personnage
marquant beaucoup des gens sont attachés
aux personnages à la femme elle-même
mais ne savent pas jusqu'à quel point la
monarchie va pouvoir tenir le coup il ya
eu énormément de scandales au cours des
dernières années au sein de la famille
royale on pense au point au prince
andrew par exemple est le prince harry
qui a décidé de quitter donc des gens se
demandent si l'institution va pouvoir
survivre au-delà du règne de la reine
elizabeth les gens ne se disent pas prêt
à contempler la question mais oui on
croise ici et là des gens qui sont des
républicains convaincus avec qui
souhaite mettre fin à la monarchie on
les entend un peu moins ces derniers
temps bon alors écoutez on vous voulez
c'est comme ça surveiller voit ce qui se
passe autour du palais de buckingham
vous allez être bien placé tout à
l'heure pour voir revenir tous ces gens
et où le cartel dans les vues superbes
également sur le balcon d'après ce que
je peux voir alors marié moi vous
retrouvez donc à peu près bon d'aller je
crois que ce soit vous du fait de ces je
sais mais à peu près nationale
à bientôt
et l'on voit que effectivement dans la
cour des cascades tout est en place la
cérémonie sur le point de commencer je
vais vous avez que j'ai pas reconnu les
écuyers ceux qui sont montés je présume
que le prince s'est certainement vous
éclairer là dessus
parce que c'est le prince charles en
voix oui oui et là c'est le prince
william qui se place à sa droite on le
reconnaît très justement ou plus mais le
kilo sur le bonnet de poils c'est la
façon de les distinguer deux régiments à
l'autre et lors de celles qu'on ne voit
pas c'est la princesse anne avoir fait
de la tête de chances de son cheval mais
elle et à sa gauche et lé
colonel dû avouer noyau donc c'est les
trois membres de la famille royale qui
sont
qui présidait ce défilé et la cérémonie
on va commencer le très très rapidement
parce que évidemment comme
les gens râlent côté le mentionner c'est
il ya eu des pratiques
ya eu deux pratiques là les deux
dernières fins de semaine alors on a
vraiment lors tout et immunités et c'est
ce que les gens me ce que ces cérémonies
leur à grand déploiement ya toujours des
répétitions alors on l'a on voit le
prince
george à la fenêtre et la duchesse de
cambridge à une autre fenêtre et l'effet
du a depuis lors que les tout petits
fellahs progressant dans une autre
fenêtre alors elle aussi pour eux pour
se reprendre c'est toujours des
spectacles paraître sans à surveiller
[Musique]
et
alors question voilà pour ces militaires
on vient de briser la glace vraiment le
le défilé la marche est commencé tout
est bien synchronisés on verra toutes
sortes de manoeuvres au fait si
l'exécutif on est en reprise est
particulièrement difficile aussi
lorsqu'on mélange les styles de musique
parce que la vitesse de marche dès
particulièrement pour lire les tous les
régiments qui utilisent la cornemuse
c'est plus là alors que la cadence
normale et 120 pour minutes à la
cornemuse de ses 90 pas mes notes alors
c'est assez difficile de tout coordonner
sens et puis lorsqu'on assiste justement
ce défilé de la musique qui représente
en fait
c'est pas juste la musique d'un seul
régime bahia plusieurs régiments qui
sont dans cette musique lors ils sont
maintenant au port à lens et qui
d'ailleurs pas ta confortable la fragile
assure
effectivement et chacun de ses résultats
ou de six group est de pouvoir effectuer
bon
une marche comme ça on va également
laisser lui le prince charles parce que
c'est lui qui remplace s'arrête il
s'était dit la reine qu'on devrait voir
là sous huy j'allais dire un chapiteau
sous un dais je pense le dézonage se
sont dits
oui mais elle a délégué la fonction
auprès charles et c'est ce qu'on voit
depuis un certain nombre de mois que de
plus en plus elle délègue des fonctions
de cette nature à l'héritier du trône et
c'est cette une façon d'une belle
transition en douceur qui est en train
de se faire vers le prochain ring et l
île de man consciente que elle n'est pas
éternelle et que le prince charles mais
doucement
le fait de participer à tous aux
cérémonies bien lorsque lorsqu'il sera
devenu boire mais pour
les gens ça va être bon ben yenni s'il a
déjà fait alors ça se poursuit la
transition force est très lourd pourquoi
ne pas sont plus faciles oui oui vous
avez raison parce que il faut pas perdre
de vue que celui qu'on voit chambre un
légèrement de 20 il y a juste derrière
son fils et le petit-fils au balcon on
avait les trois prochains marque d'un
jeune à peu près le temps d'une minute
d'image non c'est tout et c'est
important quand on parle de monarchique
parce que vous voulez on l'est on les
voit très bien la
wii on voit là la seule elle la
succession elle l'arbre il ya il ne sera
pas modifié
lorsque la reille de sakho sera
évidemment l'aprécial km à votre honneur
poids
dia pas c'est pas du tout dans les plans
que de sauter une génération loin de là
j'ai arrêté tout de suite là dessus est
ce que est ce que d'abord ça existait ce
qu'un code pour dire bon est ce que est
ce que la reine peut dire on va sauter
l'étape de charles est ce que charles
peut dire non mois avant même d'avoir le
titre déjà dit je comprends alors que le
pour exprimer mais est-ce que c'est même
possible dans la constitution dans les
règles de la monarchie non pas vraiment
je l'avais premièrement comme vous
l'avez mentionné un four initiant la
reine le jour de ses
21 ans le 26 avril 1947 à lundi je dis
merci au service c'est une violente de
ma vie soyons ou pour je donne ma vie au
service tic dont elle elle durera
jusqu'à la finale le 6 février dernier
love
la survie de la section et leurs
élections je vais toujours jusqu'à la
fin et en parle parce que la province a
retenu
je serai que
senior soit écornée rennes pour sa route
et du roi chave donc c'est évident que
pour elle c'est comme ça va de soi que
après elle c'est le prince charles et
avec son épouse qui vont être sur le
trône et de sauter une génération selon
plus c'est
c'est pas du tout dans les plans on sait
très bien que le prince charles depuis
qui depuis que tout jeune enfant qui se
prépare ce rôle ainsi les avances à 73
73 ans il l'a pas encore mais il reste
que il est conscient que lui aussi s'en
prendre votre règne de transition et que
lorsque le s'asseoir autour du prince
william de régnier bien il va avoir déjà
apporté des modifications parce qu'on
sent très très bien que il ya déjà des
objectifs
qui veut atteindre au cours de son règne
évidemment les règles on ne sait jamais
s'ils vont être longs ou courts et à 73
ainsi la longévité de sa mère il peut
faire un port certainement de bonne
vingtaine d'années une bonne vingtaine
d'années parce qu'on a dit il ya de bons
gènes dans cette famille on pense à la
reine mère également qui est décédé bon
delà du
web
effectivement alors là mais le prince
deviendrait je pense deviendrait pas le
roi le plus vieux accéder au trône aussi
à
73 ou à peu près
oui oui il va devenir parce qu il est le
prince de galles qui qui est le plus
celui qui a été qu'ils prince de galles
le plus âgé donc qui devient le roi oui
ça va être aussi le le roi alors je
crois avoir ce qui s'offre trois
villages et là à attendre attendre le 30
mai signe là encore on se posera peut
être dans quelques semaines comme l'a
fait encore dans quelques années et on
va souhaiter à la reine elizabeth ii
pouvoir
détrôner le roi
louis xiv de france qui a régné 72 ans
et plus donc la date butoir c'est le 27
mai 2024 alors se situe presse à 2020 27
mai 2024 donc on va se frotter à la
reine isabelle de pouvoir dépasser
cette date et ainsi être la souveraine
pas avoir régné le plus longtemps au
monde mais je crois dans quelques jours
d'ailleurs contre le roi de thaïlande
avec le ce que ça c'est le champion
souffle
c'est le rhode island c'est le 12 juin
prochain que la reine va dépasser son
sang hwa jour là datera ce club weeks en
rien ces araignées 70's en huit jours
donc le 12 juin prochain la reine va
dépasser elle va être en deuxième
position pour le mandat qui a régné
depuis longtemps monde
donc que c'est c'est beaucoup si
plusieurs années
[Musique]
plutôt de rein qu'elle pose en planches
posées évidemment le passage des
conseils des draps boues sont pas encore
sur le terrain pad alors ça doit être la
prochaine étape la voie à toutes les
musiques de protection des drapeaux
consacrée qui devrait arriver sur le
terrain
[Musique]
on était souvent
on parle de 22 visite qu'elle a faits au
canada
peut-être qu'on leur marque dans ces
deux pays qu'elle a visité le plus
souvent je crois qu'on y est
elle est là était aussi présente dans
tous les pays du commonwealth
ce qui est assez particulier aussi parce
que finalement il ya plus d'un empire
britannique comme tel mais il ya quand
même le lien commonwealth qui réunit
quand même plusieurs pays
ce différents continents aussi là elle à
accéder quand il est devenue la reine
avait vite nation comme un annuaire
maintenant bon écouter leurs aptitudes
et des
53 je pense alors au delà 53 et des pays
qui n'étaient pas dans le commonwealth
ou quand ils ont obtenu leur
indépendance qui m a dû quitter mais
finalement après réflexion puis
peut-être quelques années d'histoire
quand tout sur place et on est revenu
d'un des leurs comme un noir on regarde
l on a parlé tout à l'heure des
allemands qui faisait peut-être une
allusion à le fait qu'ils aimeraient
rétabli la hiérarchie
royal dans leur pays je pense pas que ce
soit un souhait partagé par tous les
allemands mais néanmoins il ya quand
même un lien sert très fort trois avis
la monarchie allemande et la monarchie
anglaise et puis à tel point que
certains moment donné on parle beaucoup
de l'ordre louer ce matin mais c'est pas
son vrai nom à son vrai nom s'était bâti
bègue beac choisit montagne dans les ont
simplement transposer les particules du
nom poids pour un glee 6 est ni plus ni
moins sont en mode battle et puis il
fait tout ça c'est arrivé
tout seul c'est arrivé pendant la
première guerre parce que les anglais
les anglais disait que bon le nom de
notre famille royale sussex cobourg
gotha c'est très allemand est ce qu'ils
ont pour un peu
une appréciation pour les allemands mais
même si on est en guerre contre eux
alors leurs proches georges 5 a décidé
de changer le nom de la dynastie et ça
c'est fait le 17 juillet 1917 et il a
choisi sur la recommandation de son
secrétaire particulier
le nom de windsor à la city wenders et
je ne peux pas être plus anglais c'est
comme ça que et les membres de la
famille qui avaient des noms allemands à
consonance allemande ils ont été comme
justement les batailles blogs sont
devenus des monts barton et il y en a eu
d'autres que c'est les noms ont été
modifiés comme ça et de cette façon là
bien on effacer
un peu un peu plus leur régional membre
de la famille parce que si on remonte au
de quelques siècles le roi d'angleterre
ne parle même pas l'anglais ne parlait
seulement l'alma donc évidemment même la
reine victoria elle a marié son cousin
mais c'était un allemand le prince
albert était un allemand donc c'est pour
ça que en 1917 on a changé le nom de la
dynastie et leur maintenant que c'est la
reine elizabeth qui est sur le trône
évidemment il ya été au tout début de
son règne on a dit bon mais là on est
plus dans la dynastie windsor mais on
est dans la dynastie wang battle est
très très rapidement la reine a fait
savoir que non le nom de la dynastie
restait windsor et c'est seulement 1960
que la la reine
déterminé que ses enfants et ses
descendants porterait le nom de man
battle windsor pour justement que le nom
du prince philippe soient
incorporées dans le patronyme de la
famille mais des enfants et des petits
enfants et arrière maintenant
petits-enfants
de la reine elizabeth ii et du prince
philip
alors si je vous pose une question parce
que pas de questions vous savez sorte il
faut toutes les poses et donc quand on
voit les oiseaux dans la série de crown
la couronne où le prince a pas l'air
très content de devoir concéder son nom
que c'était vrai donc ça ce moment alors
quand elle a maintenant 15 ans en cap et
leurs voiliers présent la télévision n'a
vu que l'officier a changé russie arrive
encore a reçu le drapeau
régimentaire et vous avez vu la garde de
sécurité que je suis placé là de façon
cérémonial
imposition de protection justement et
encore une fois c'est très symbolique
temps on veut protéger le drapeau alors
vous voyez maintenant y occuper le rang
juste en avant de cette garden qui
protège le drapeau et puis généralement
nous en fait dans les exercices
militaires canadiens il ya toujours au
moins deux personnes armées qui sont qui
protège de drapeaux
alors les couleurs ont vécu là c'est ce
drapeau retenue parce c'est officiel
salt officiers effectivement là où vous
le voyez derrière le commandant et puis
les gens ils vont probablement
défilé avec le le drapeau comme tel pour
le montrer à tous
ces lots je trouverais d'accord de
sa signification aux évènements ont
tourné par un dunk outre les propos
qu'elle peut voir
établie à calais le nouveau drapeau
quand même un régime relativement jeu
ce maillot là des 7900 ces bornes c'est
pas aussi longue
une histoire que certains autres juments
de la household les jeunes c'est quand
même régime à qui a été aussi en
afghanistan qui a été
conscient de grammaire à lui
[Musique]
repoussé nos questions quand on connaît
le contexte le rôle de l'armée
britannique en irlande du nord quand on
entend comme cela garde irlandaise est
ce que quel genre
je commence avec vous oui mais stoppé je
me sois vous entendent également là
dessus est-ce que ce que c'est délicat
ce que c'est sensible à ce qu il ya une
tension présume que des catholiques en
irlande genre qu'est ce qu'il pense
quand il voit les garder en vie ben en
fait
il ya quand même beaucoup de questions
seront pas encore résolu mais ça je me
rappelle quelqu'un qui est devenu le
général en chef de toutes les forces
armées britanniques du porte un nom
assez le jul michael jackson lui étaient
en irlande lorsqu'il y avait eu des
embuscades pour certains membres de
l'aea riz mais finalement son nom avait
été blanchi si on veut dans tout ça
parce qu'il y avait eu beaucoup des
allégations comme de quake cette
embuscade là c'était réellement plutôt
du curriculum muscade spontanée alors
ça a été cette est très lent et ça a
laissé encore des blessures ou vers le
succès en 30 est peut-être de se rouvrir
à nouveau parce que la
leaf actions plus radicales
irlandaise est en train de prendre le
pouvoir politique l'a alors peut-être
que ça va changer beaucoup et puis on
sait que le break site apporter de
nouvelles dimensions lauda dans toutes
les relations entre l'angleterre et
l'irlande alors ça ça demande un délicat
c'est ce que la haine comme tel par sa
diplomatie aussi et par ses discours a
toujours réussi à apaiser les
problématiques qui se posent là entre
différentes factions que ce soit les
écossais versus les angles où les
gallois versus l'angleterre mais elle
est très rassembleuse et c'est
probablement la chose qui va se
démarquer le plus lorsque elle va céder
le trône à son successeur je pense pas
que le prince charles a autant
d'empathie donc que l'arrêt
restait là dessus vous le la présence
des gardes irlandais c'est ça c'est pas
si c'est comme le sera le disent c'est
une situation extrêmement délicate la
reine actuelle
est là et il ya quelques années
ouvrir le parlement ça c'était les gens
craignaient
pour sa présence en iran mais finalement
ça s'est bien déroulé
mais je crois que lorsque le front
le présence rassure le trompe
lui aussi il va essayer
26,9 à la même approche je convaincu
qu'ils vont essayer de deux de calmer le
jeu et d'essayer de devoir de trouver
des solutions parce que le prince
charles est très
ouvert à de nouvelles confrères l'eau
présentement dans le règne finissant de
l'art musa bête on est comme
tout reste en plan rien ne bouge
beaucoup mais on sent très bien que lors
du prochain règle il va avoir des
changements qui vont être apportées et
et de différentes natures on doit
seulement qu'à penser aux cominois je
suis convaincu que
la structure actuelle pour être
étudiée et il va avoir des changements
qui ont été apportés c'est à quel point
cela va affecter les différents membres
ça reste évidemment à voir ça ce propos
le le nord met son accession au trône
mais il va avoir certainement une remise
en question de la structure actuelle et
comment on peut l'adapter au betis est
et voir comment les différents pays qui
sont au mans est différente monarchique
en font partie comment ils peuvent se
visiter c'est peut-être laquelle canada
votre tête et trouve plus enfants
d'alors médecin il ya tellement de gens
qui disent qu il faudrait en sortir donc
ça ça reste à voir et avec les rendent
c'est un peu la même chose mais il reste
qu'
il ya eu beaucoup de décisions qui vont
se prendre mais
dans les années à venir se soucier
certains il va avoir beaucoup de
modifications
du road
du mandat oui parce que la reine a
traversé dans des dernières années les
vingt dernières années des difficultés
familiales avec des divorces et des
querelles entre les frais mais le brésil
sait c'est pas de son recense elle s'est
tenu d'ailleurs si je ne m'abuse c'est s
est pas prononcé sur la question
la reine la reine est en règle mais le
gouverneur sortant ce sont des questions
c'est le parlement élu qui doit régler
s'il ya ces situations là elle est leur
devoir elle peut de consulter le premier
ministre la rencontre soit son avis en
particulier comme on disait plutôt même
le secrétaire privé n'est pas là donc
elle peut vraiment dire à son premier
ministre
donner des suggestions mettre en garde
et on sait que deux elle a une
expérience politique incroyable donc
elle est là elle peut apporter le
déconseille qui autrement
ça serait pas donné mais de donner son
opinion sera un thème en particulier
elle l'a jamais fait et je suis
convaincu qu'elle ne sera jamais donc
plus s'aimer c'est
elle a le pouvoir de dire mais attention
si on va de sa côte est ont peu à voir
telle ou telle réaction mais c'est une
discussion en pleuvait et les premiers
ministres aucun premier ministre que eu
l'audace de vraiment révéler ce qu'il
disait dans ces réunions hebdomadaires
entre le soleil la souveraine et
le 1er mai lire ça ça reste les
conversations nos privée notre dame et
qui ont certainement aidé à un ou
l'autre des premiers mini sauf aux deux
parce que leurs quinze 15 différents
premier ministre au cours de son règne
donc
chacun il ya été de sa de ses idées
parce que c'est évidemment son compte
même parti politique
les époques changent ya tellement de
données différents de moment un autre
que mais elle a arrêté un continuum qui
a fait que l le plus avec sa grande
expérience de données
des conseils des avis dans certains
cercles
[Musique]
il a défilé devant toutes les troupes et
puis chaque fois qu'il passe d'avoir un
truc différent ceux-ci se placer en
position qu'on y présentait à part le
manque de respect pour le dans la peau
et puis là je présume que l'on devrait
changer de formation et puis on voit
défiler sans doute avec cette nouvelle
formation qui sont en train d'adopter
puis on a vu aussi que le groupe de
protection rapprochée du drapeau s'est
constitué c'est à dire qu'il ya deux
choses aussi qui sont de chaque côté du
porte drapeau et nous aussi à l'arrière
et ceux ci sont toujours armés avec
baïonnette au canon
très important ça c'est seb est le même
en 2020 de baïonnette au canon c'est oui
mais ça veut dire qu'on est prêt à
défendre cette manne oui et puis c'est
encore utiliser les baïonnettes là c'est
plus psychologique si on n'aime pas ce
que se fait déchirer par une baïonnette
c'est toujours un peu délicat pour les
personnes qui qui doivent être confronté
un sommet cinq ans sa place à baïonnette
et dans les autres cérémonies on pouvait
voir ce qui est également impressionnant
l'épée que tient cet officier
c'est j'en veux dire c'est une antiquité
c'est une arme de famille il ya toutes
ces possibilités la wii et puis chacun
jumaa ses propres particularités pour
les pays aussi et puis il y avait aussi
est ce qu'on appelle le gland le gland
c'est réellement là
une parure d'or équipe à
près de dimanche de libé alors les
régiment écossais on les paie
complètement différente kirkouk la main
les
la majorité des régimes sains qui sont
de tradition britannique prcg plus
souvent il ya juste une demi
protection de la main mais c'est la
longueur aussi du du canton comme tel
indique le grade de la personne alors il
ya beaucoup de deux petites
particularités comme ça donc il faut
réellement le savoir de façon à melaka
cas pour rien si je vous pose des
questions sur mes envoyer des dés
des militaires canadiens imparable est
ce qu'elle est le même le même souci du
détail sont actionnés français le 14
juillet c'est la même chose si chaque
abri un détail comme swiss films à ya
certaines et puis c'est ça fait partie
des manoeuvres militaires ça peut c'est
toute une école
de pensée aussi pour justement obliger
tout le monde à passer aux détails les
plus infimes parce que cantonal en
opération il faut aussi être capable de
penser à l'impensable alors si si on est
capable de tout pensé ça est évidemment
faux il faut dire que le contexte
opérationnel est différent mais vous
avez la fatigue s'installe même de
grandes parades qu'il faut jamais
oublier les mots de coma pour jabobs
yelema 9 pas bon et puis anticipé aussi
les prochains commandement dont
quelqu'un qui minutieux avec l'uniforme
avec la longueur des de toutes les
décorations de toi et parra on peut on
peut on espère et on dit c'est la même
chose sur un théâtre de combats si on
m'avait dit de se placer 1 à 3 mètres
c'est pas moins de trois mètres qui va
devoir mettre effectivement et puis si
on faisait aussi des rois tout son
équipement prêt pour des raisons
opérationnelles bien il ya tout un
protocole là dessus on veut savoir où
sont ses six munitions de rechange au
coït en beau combat hop tels qu'un doigt
doit prendre ces munitions pour
se réapprovisionner alors tous deux
têtes
codifie si on veut ouais alors la
présentant les troupes de phil justement
et pira en principe elle devrait défiler
devant le des royals où la reine retour
vers
le salut et puis le présent demain son
taux pour relancer vie d'avant
bon alors restez là je vois des chapeaux
je vois des dames avec des châteaux
naturel bateau bol de dit qu'est ce que
c'est l'histoire avec les chapeaux
c'est lors d'une cérémonie comme cela
c'est obligatoire pour les dames de
porter le chapeau
c'est par
ses traditionnels dans ce genre
d'événement la
légende et les femmes aiment bien
justement avoir l'occasion de porter un
style même si des vêtements modernes de
retrouver le chapeau les gants les
les souliers à talons fins alors c c'est
la prédiction
l'angleterre c'est un pays de tradition
alors sûr c'en est une
évidemment on sait aussi que la reine
dans dans tous ses déplacements
public elle porte toujours un chapeau
les gars donc c est pour c'est une
fierté les gens sont fial sont fiers et
on a vu autant les femmes sont sont
élégantes avec leurs chapeaux la
toilette mais les hommes au 660 en
habits et je crois que
même que dans lorsque les gens ont reçu
ceux qui ont eu la chance de gagner les
billets pour assister à la cérémonie on
doit même fort probable à avoir de
spécifier un code vestimentaire sur les
1 les invitations donc je suis convaincu
que dans une telle cérémonie
vote sandales pas de
jeans ou de vêtements alors un peu
de
joueurs
réguliers ces points 15 joueuses d un
ces points je dis que je dis et en
analyse
voyez-les on vient juste de voir
justement le porte drapeau qui vient de
baisser le drapeau celui qu'on appelle
le salut royal effectivement puisqu'il
passe devant la famille royale alors
c'est
généralement pour les autres ça lui nous
disons que si c'est celle du premier
mais n'est ce pas ce moment là c'est
uniquement qu'on laisse flotter le
drapeau mais pour la famille royale on
ne le sait lui en baisse le drapeau à ce
moment là et là vous voyez justement
sous le drapeau sont marqués tous les
honneurs de bataille du régime 1 et en
ardenne
[Musique]
et puis là ils sont en position de salut
c'est à dire qu ils ont la tête à droite
pour justement signifier qu'ils saluent
la famille royale et la famille royale
doit évidemment répondre en salles 20
sont aux aussi
on peut comprendre que marché comme cela
un respecter la ligne chaussée c'est
moins facile la date c'est pas tout le
monde qui est capable de maîtriser le
porc lentilles veux vous dire une
affaire
anoh toutes les sortes
c'est le second des problèmes
physiologiques
[Musique]
et il faut souligner que cette année
c'est bon ça va parce que l'on est
rapproché on est presque pour les
épaules c'est tout juste si on ne touche
pas mais l'an passé à windsor afin de
respecter les deux mètres c'était une
tout autre serbe a dit on regardait la
grande pelouse d'un stade dans le
château à monza et là on voyait les
manèges on avait deux mètres d'à peu
près toutes les directions oui oui
et justement la reine était seul avec
son cousin le duc de quelqu'un qui était
avec elle mais ce sont les deux
dernières années ça a été extrêmement ça
a été très différent de ce qu'on était
mieux à voir mais là on retourne
vraiment à ce que la cérémonie a
toujours été et c'est évidemment et en
plus les deux dernières années il n'y
avait pas de spectateurs c'était
uniquement les militaires alors que la
viola trouve que les gens qui sont dans
les extras mais aussi le tout les gens
qui sont le long du parcours le long du
mall et c'est cela la différence avec
les dernières années mais malgré tout la
série menu avec frites animée
elle aurait pu facilement est annulé
mais
on a décidé qu'on l'a frais mais en
respectant certaines règles aux notes
des deux mains est en trop mais typique
de la résilience de cette génération là
dont fait partie la reine isabelle celle
qui a traversé la deuxième guerre
mondiale et c'est un symbole c'est un
message qu'il semble d'un lien lancé un
moment donné il y aura un transfert
l'avenir c'est ceux qui sont présents là
à cette cérémonie dans la cour
ce sont les futurs
rois de l'angleterre il ya une
transition elle n'a jamais caché qu'elle
l'a toujours dit c'est ça la reine mère
également qu'ils disaient laisser faire
les bombardements je vais encore voir
l'est de londres
ben oui mais la rumeur l'envoie georges
au début de la deuxième guerre il était
question que justement la reine
elizabeth i la reine-mère et les deux
petites princesses viennent se réfugier
au canada et elle a dit
je peux pas partir se méfie moi je peux
pas partir salle et là il la voit peu
faut quitter l'angleterre moi je peux
profiter le roi donc toute la famille
reste en angleterre et les deux
princesses ont été vives au château de
windsor et la réalisa dette et le roi
george vi e on restait à boké niall et
il y avait un abri sous le château et il
ya eu le palais était aussi bombardé la
salle de musique a été complètement
détruite et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'elle a dit
lorsqu'elle a été rencontré des gens de
là dans le système c'est la partie qui
est le plus touché en angleterre pendant
la deuxième guerre est lady b l'heure je
veux au moins regarder les gens en face
lorsque nous aussi ont été bombardés
donc et on sait que l'a précisé bête dès
qu'elle a eu 18 ans elle dit moi je veux
aussi faire le mont et pas pour faire la
guerre donc
lcl s'est joint au groupe d eds
et elle s'est mis à le suivi un cours
pour être mécanicienne est alors ribéry
des véhicules militaires
pendant les quelques mois à la fin à la
fin de la guerre en 45 donc est ce
d'ailleurs pour ça que
lorsque le but mais lorsqu'un venue la
journée là qui ont célébré la fin de la
guerre la princesse elisabeth était en
uniforme militaire au balcon du château
du palais de buckingham
[Musique]
ouais c'est peu
qu'on va avoir complété tout le circuit
auto de terrain de rassemblement avec
la marche au pas ralenti je pense qu'on
va faire normalement le même trajet mais
au pas normal du progamme ac c'est
exactement ce qui se produit il ya de
changer le rythme de la musique là de
façon à l'est un peu plus gaillards
demain
et s'excentre faire parce que tout est
calculé là il ya également il ya un
officier qui est responsable également
jeu rythme un pcet heures oui aux
poissons dans les voitures de course
tandis qu il ya quelqu un qui calque une
seule qui peut dans son sommeil comptait
1 120 pas de doute pour quelque chose
comme ça écoutez ils ont ils ont aussi
une école pour les sous-officiers juste
maps droit commun
monter des parades comme ça vous des
scénarios de parade est tous métaux ou
alors
c'est assez bien développé l'armée
britannique
quand je constate que les chevaux elle
aime dire c'est normal quand on fait des
défilés mais dépendamment des groupes et
on dirait peut-être même dépendamment
des postes qu'on occupe durant qu'on
occupe les chevaux sont noir ou brun oui
il y en a un blanc au leblanc pensée
royal
parce que le cru comprendre que parce
que les stèles avoue des explications là
dessus parce que j'en ai entendu
certaines explications là dessus et on
remonte au champ de bataille
dantin bah oui commun comme djellal la
blague qu'on entendait souvent de quelle
couleur était le cheval blanc de
napoléon alors c'était réellement pour
peut-être justement pour signifier qui
était le chef est visible encore
effectivement tourisme est attendu à
brest elle sait ce qu'elle est les sites
ça prend des gens de vapeur safran ce
type de distinction l'eau pour être
capable de reconnaître les mythes les
amis ou et les les chevaux les chapeaux
avec les certains types de classes et
c'est vrai pas vous le dire exactement
je devrais le vérifier mais il reste que
c'est ça fait beaucoup de sens que même
la regarder on envoie un cheval blanc à
l'écran derrière le prince charles donc
chacun à une certaine signification ça
c'est surfait et
met habituellement les lys à vous de là
il semble que les chapeaux de la
drogue sont ils sont noirs alors les
autres ça ça peut être d'autres
régiments mais parce que dans les bateys
y avait beaucoup de
fumée et de flammes de poussière si on
voulait savoir parce que si on est tous
montés sur des chevaux noirs fallait
savoir où était le commandant ou l
officier qui mène notre notre unité
alors il est il est à cheval blanc parce
que là on pouvait le voir aussi et c'est
pour ça qu'on est l'étendard également
salué la direction où aller en combo le
cheval blanc du ticket ou était ou est à
notre notre fier
et puis c'est pour ça aussi que les
couleurs sont très variables
rouge des ray ban les couleurs des
britanniques le bleu était celui de
l'armée française et puis c'était
réellement pour se distinguer justement
mais par la suite ça a évolué parce que
le premier qui ont eu une couleur de de
camouflage c'est elle les allemands avec
le ce qu'on appelait le feld grao le
guérit de campagne si on veut et puis ça
se confondait bien avec la brune et tout
et tout alors c'était moins voyants mais
pendant longtemps justement à cause de
ce cursus machiavel sous les champs de
bataille vous n'avez des détenus très
voyage très voyante les métis canadien
reculait redonner sens comme comme
formation aux allemands
ou troupe de riels
des cachets et puis les batailles en
renversant la belle bataille à rats se
faisait de façon très diplomatique le
déroff devait avancer jusqu'à une
certaine distance pour permettre à
l'autre de nous tirer dessus oui alors
c'est pas une
autre idée en tête
c'est un combat capables de chira ya qui
était encore plus agile et rapide
le service militaire est en fait la
carrière militaire c'est important pour
tous les membres de la famille royale de
charles williams jo ils ont tous ses
étés
dans tous des fonctions wi ont tous été
belle mais marie aussi le site est
difficile de déployer ils ont tous été
et sont plus où tous étaient déployés
oui en fait harry que ce qu'on en parle
lui était pilote d'hélicoptère de combat
oui on a bien dû ce temps et puis
je crois que
ses frères presque tous été d'un pilote
de l'armée de terre
le prince a été aussi le cas pendant
la guerre des malouines de oui et puis
le prince charles a été commandant de
frégate pendant
sa carrière navale des années 70 donc le
prince philippe a été aussi pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale il ya était
sur un bateau ouais donc ça a été oui
c'est ça fait ça fait partie comme des
normes tous les
membres de la famille royale
font faire un stage phone carrière plus
ou moins longues évidemment plus on est
près du tronc plus c'est difficile de
les déployer parce qu'il ya toujours de
la question de sécurité on l'a vu avec
le prince harry est en fait
de
deux campagnes en afghanistan mais
finalement ils étaient eux-mêmes disent
ainsi si je peux pas aller avec mon
régiment ça me donne quoi d'être dans
l'armée alors il ya été mais la première
fois qu'il a été déployée en afghanistan
on le sus seulement à son retour la
journée qu'il est revenu le dit vas y
revient de l'afghanistan la deuxième
fois on le sud avance mais ça a été sa
sécurité était autour de lui le
souhaitait très très serré parce que
évidemment c'est il avait été capturé
vous imaginez le problème diplomatique
que cela règle cela aurait causé alors
et le prince william a pas été
déployés
dans un milieu de guerre mais il s'est
occupé lors de
d'être pilote d'hélicoptère dans des
missions de sauvetage ou sur la côte
anglaise donc vous aider cette leçon de
bonne partie
celui de la famille royale s'était
déployée aux malouines savait était
connu par les argentins et puis il y
avait véritablement trac pour le oui oui
oui oui elle vraiment y'a pas de on est
sans pitié parce que tout à l'heure on
the keys allemand avait bombardé le
palais de buckingham
ouais mais là maintenant à vous donc il
y avait c'était pas juste le juste des
craintes 2006
s'étaient connus et puis il voulait en
fait
capturez les pollens super tôt le petit
prince à
savoir un cauchemar pour un commandant
d'avoir des membres de familles royales
effectivement c'est parce que leur faut
veiller à la protection des victimes pas
ça ça c'est un peu comme perdre le
drapeau du matin le décès c'est une
honte il y au président que le ce soldat
de la famille royale veut se battre aux
côtés de ses collègues pixels partie des
boys d1 de son entourage il veut
certainement pas un traitement de faveur
non alors il faut concilier les deux
effectivement et puis c'est ça devrait
être facile évidemment lorsqu'on est
pilote d'hélicoptère ben alors c'est
différent parce que c'est plus
individuelle
malgré qu'ils opèrent toujours à pair
ouais et puis
c'est pas de tête dans l'adjudication
des missions qu'on lui confie qu'il faut
être un peu plus prudent mais dès qu'on
met peut-être un peu trop de watts pour
le protéger mais là ils peuvent se
rebiffer aussi plaidé laisser faire là
je fais mon travail comme les nôtres
alors c'est tout ce qu'il faut concilier
pour le commandant local qui doit
réellement prendre soin ça veut dire que
l'on a le bureau du premier ministre si
l'on prend l'exemple des britanniques
qui qui va qui voit sommé son me disent
la défense de dire tu vas parler au
kung
fu mais quand même souligner ou canada
n'a pas une grosse tradition militaire
chez nos politiciens n'ont pas évolué à
gérer les problèmes comme celui là les
rend pas du tout pas du tout
faites-la ils vont procéder encore à la
remise en condition des rats
ça ce cas ils vont toutes se réaligner
quand date la musique que vous jouez
encore
[Musique]
donc musiciens nos musiciens militaires
sont presque toutes les radios et des
conservatoires universités alors faite
aux médecins des points de lille 1 et
les musiciens professionnels non je sais
pas si à la même mesure ça se produit
dans l'armée britannique mais mais s'ils
sont diplômés de conservatoires
qui sont dans l'armée ils ont les ils
ont des métiers digital métier militaire
de musiciennes sont musiciens temps
plein à temps plein ahmed adam les dans
les musiques officielles comme la
musique du royal 22e régiment a sondé et
musiciens temps plein alors c'est quoi
des combats mécanicien s'ils sont bien
distincts non je suis sont déployés un
réel mal en cas de guerre bat il servira
de bras cardié ou des choses là d'accord
puis seraient dépouillés ou si vous
mettez le moral des troupes en faisant
des prestations musicales
alors c'est tout
c'est un jeune et qu'on n'a pas
réellement eu guère en fait on est en
afghanistan mais on n'a jamais déclaré
la guerre c'était les opérations
maintenance et c'est réellement
sur la saveur du moment on utilise le
mot opération mais y apporte réellement
déclaration de guerre de façon
très marquée très diplomatique très
très protocolaire comme auparavant on
faisait pour la première la deuxième
guerre mondiale vous m'apprenez quelque
chose j'ai pensé que c'était des gens
qui étaient déjà qu'ils avaient un
talent musical et puis qui pouvait faire
ça je pars un jour par semaine où on a
deux cp des moujiks volontaires et les
musiques professionnels comme la musique
du royal 22e régiment à la musique
centrale la musique de la marine
canadienne la musique de l'aviation
royale canassons des musiciens
professionnels la table alors la voie
loterie six as et c'est ce qui est
spectaculaire sur des montures noires
comme estelle est ce que ça une honte ce
genre de pression il faut en fait
remonter moi j'ai pensé à la police
montée notre jr 6 qui est ce qu'un homme
pour ce genre de formation ça c'est
spectaculaire aussi oui c'est c'était
très sympa formation que je pourrais pas
vous dire ce n'est pas parce que je
connais pas et puis vous remarquerez
aussi que ce que ce que prétend maulawi
bat la mesure oui ben c'est des chevaux
de trait oui mais je vois c'est costaud
parce que quand même et on peu
d'équipement aussi celui qui pèse ses
tambours là haut que j'ai lu ça dans les
notes ce matin cent vingt 120 livres
alors ça vous donne une idée plus de
sakhalin lieux saints livre de livrer
deux musiciens ça vous donne une idée
assez des bed les chevaux de trait de
brouille
et puis les autres c'est s'aider des
personnes aux normes aux
coureurs
en parlant de chevaux il a été annoncé
aujourd'hui que y'a que le président
français
mc ren a donné comme cadeau à la reine
elizabeth un cheval pour cent soixante
dixième anniversaire
lorsqu'on voit cdd jean d'artillerie
royal et puis ils ont avec eux à ce
moment là ils font défiler leur drapeau
leur drapeau ce sont les canons oui oui
et puis encore une fois la fierté des
orties ya c'est de protéger leurs canons
et
pour la petite histoire
on dit que 26 cas non là c'est les mêmes
groupes que les autres années un de ces
canons a tiré le premier coup de la
bataille de somme à mon sens
mais ce qui m'épate c'est mary j pardon
merci pour les femmes oui mais j'ai
d'autres commentateurs d'entraidé ça
veut donc dire qu'on les a conservées
tout ça c'est des relais
conditions
extraordinaires bon alors ici on a un
cortège là je suis un peu surpris je
vais position dominante encore mais
aussi les différentes qu'en 2001 corps
d'armes qui comme là ce sont les
artistes qui ont des idées et puis avec
la tenue de
tenues traditionnelles les orties à un
but justement web canon en question avec
la cravache lakic a une position très
particulière aussi de salutations oui
oui
par la suite ma foi ça devrait
probablement terminée le mal parce qu'il
ya repos à ma connaissance on ne verra
pas de jardin sous
les chars d'assaut en fait est
représentée par les troupes montées
qu'on a vues totale avec la tenue
de
traditionnel chapeau à une puis la
cuirasse de pau traîne
et voilà alors les autres représentent
encore une fois non seulement la
cavalerie mais les blindés alors les
principaux
groupes militaires de l'armée de terre
sont représentés infanterie artillerie
les blessés
[Musique]
passée la même tenue que la garde
républicaine dans france ton regard sont
dans ces domaines même type de tenue
avec chapeau arômes comme ça et puis qu
il rase le poteau
et puis il ya des monarques qui au fil
des 100 paires ont également ajouté des
détaillants dans le design de ses seins
souvent c'est parce qu'ils ont peut-être
influencé aussi par le régime a dont il
est lé colonel honoraire et puis ils ont
décidé d'imposer sa à leurs gardes comme
tel vous voyez quelle couleur différente
aussi le pôle heures
le chapeau
au
passé rouge
[Musique]
ce sont des pionniers vous voyez lâche
ce sens au lieu d'avoir une épure en feu
en une hache les pionniers ce sont ceux
qui sont responsables réel mahb
s'assurer de la destruction des haies
des équipements acquis qui pourrait
nuire à l'avance des blés d alors ils
sont responsables aussi des explosifs
planter des explosifs à leur patron leur
saint patron c'est la sainte barbe quand
tous ceux qui
qui manipulent les explosifs s'est elle
a retiré les ingénieurs c'est la sainte
barbe
en fait
fête de la sainte barbe
alors en mesure de penser tous ces
soldats que l'on voit là un uniforme de
parade ont tous été déployée un moment
ou un autre mais un canadien qui ont
quand même des rubans fatima
donc afghanistan beaucoup irak beaucoup
pour la génération là peut-être le kiwi
qui est déployée la aujourd'hui il ya eu
quand même aussi des missions comme des
missions d'appui en lettonie en lituanie
sont des missions dans le cadre de
l'otan a lancé mission là aussi sans
sont récompensés par des médailles
quelles sont vos relations mano à mano
l'eau quand vous vous êtes à la même
table avec un général britannique
la relation pneus entre nous militaires
nous sommes dans quel genre de
coopération et esthétique de fraternité
boschi ça a beaucoup changé au fil des
ans parce que
me rappelle de les premiers
les premières occasions j'ai et
les contacts avec les autres shibutani
que c'était un peu croatie ont pesé
n'est ce pas ce qu'on n'était plus ancré
sur des des missions d'opérations
maintiennent la tête et puis par la
suite la en alain il ya cheval qui est
désordonné son cavalier je crois et puis
mais chez les choses qui arrivent du
rhin selon le paradis et puis au fil des
années au fur et à mesure qu'on a été
sur les mêmes missions bassa s'est
apaisée et puis de dialogue et un même
très bon
résume qu'avec chaque armée d'aion un
type de relation qui doit un peu
différent c'était les français ou les
américains peut-être que américains ont
déplu intégrer les américains ont
toujours dit que ondes et à une armée
qui était uniquement dévolu
aux opérations de maintien de la paix et
puis il avait une expression lorsqu'on
nous rencontrer
on la police
oui dans de windows user de windows
alors je supposais que c'était des vrais
combats tan encore une fois moi je le
rappelais que quelques airs avez vous
gagné depuis 1945
aucune et puis la ccl réel mal le défi
militaire et politique de tous les
actions et opérations militaires à
l'échelle globale il ya plus de
victoires qu'on peut proclamer de façon
claire et nette c'est serré elle mal
d'entre elles ont été aidées des
terrains de bata et puis on n'est pas
sûr réellement de ce qu'on a accompli
le plus bel exemple c'est quand on est
sortie d'afghanistan cet été d'ailleurs
ça faisait l'objet d'un gros gros débat
politique au mois d'août la rapidité
rien qu'un délit tout le monde est sorti
qu'on finit britannique ons a laissé
derrière mardi étant de guily de
traducteurs et leurs familles et si un
corps un pêle-mêle ses braquages réglés
parce que ça a laissé des blessures
assez importante d'entre ceux qui ont
qui ont su porter
l'effort des alliés de l'otan quand même
60 et pour pays ont participé à la
guerre en afghanistan
et puis plusieurs n'étaient pas de
l'otan ouais
paulhe le groupe lance finalement sur le
cavalier que ces fêtes
sont désarçonnés effectivement c'est
quand même c'est ce que je pense que je
vois la bête à l'arrière juste à la
gauche de l'écran sous l'union jack le
sujet m'abuse
[Applaudissements]
abel en attaque damas
le défilé aérien
je salue roi et un accord
quand celle de m
[Musique]
pourquoi
on atteint les hélicos frérot loi ne les
voit pas
il a tenu des des personnes qui sont
dans leur
sur la garde comme ça vous voyez que les
discussions des boutons et différentes
alors chaque régime anglais a pas
réellement une tenue particulière
et qui touche à la salle haute est
réellement le tenue à jour
il ya une tentative d'uniformiser
l'uniforme de l'armée britannique mais
les pression était trop forte en garder
un peu de fautes là
on avait comme ça au canada bayard
qui a réintroduit
[Musique]
oui c'est en 1968 qu'on avait décidé
d'avoir réellement uniforme pour tout le
monde et puis par la suite
ce nas import ça s'est pas avéré un
succès parce qu'on voulait avoir une
unité
2 capacités opérationnelles qui se
rassemblaient finalement au corps des
marines américaines mais vous ne pourrez
pas les mêmes adam ne pas non plus les
mêmes ressources sont pas non plus le
maine gygax et ce corps des marines et
quand même 185 mille personnes alors il
faut s'armer canadienne la force
permanente régulière ces soixante mille
personnes
est en fait le plafond autorisé ses 66
mm x 60
alors on voit que les troupes commencé à
quitter justement l'intérêt paraguay oui
et vous regardez le membre on les voit
si c'était l'image qu'on voyait avec
jouer lille et notre façon à l'est les
cavaliers s'en vont dans le coin die par
qu'ils ont des écuries dans ce coin là
et puis tout seul
autant les artilleurs que l'idh
tu les veux faire du tourisme je pense
qu'on peut visiter ces écuries la
critiquant la reine web en fait moi
j'avais été dans ce coin l'homme puis
effectivement envoie les chevaux aussi
dans
les news la province compte à peine dix
ans
alors l'instant c'est la fête qui va
commencer parce que si tous ces gens
bons tous ces militaires qui vont
reprendre la parade et qui vont
descendre le somptueux bal avec cette ce
pavé rose et rose et rouge là c'est
c'est de toute beauté de voir ça de
dédier les
oui c'est ça aurait pu les les gens je
suis convaincu que les gens qui
attendent sur le mile pouvoir défiler
toutes ses nombreuses grimaces
vont vont certainement les saluer avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé à date il me
semble qu'on a pas vu la mascotte moi
j'ai pas vu la mascotte du cm
mais
je suis convaincu qu'elle est là c'est
seulement que les caméras nous ne pas
montrer mais c'est un
[Musique]
serrurier et lévrier irlandais et c'est
toujours habile seulement la très belle
lettre qu'il quitterait dû supplier et
mais là on l'a pas vu alors oui j'étais
libre et pour vous en parler mais
effectivement le pauvre s'émousse je
pense qu'on le confonde la famille c'est
tout mais on l'appelle aussi ses muscles
et un an alors donc mal à
l'aller le régime a dit harish khare
d'une mascotte depuis 1902 donc
donc d'année en année
évidemment au cours des ans il y en a eu
certains dont ils en ont tous toujours
une mosquée alors voilà le mal avec les
drapeaux unis jack bien placé comme ça
ça doit absolument de toute beauté belle
journée également à londres où il n'a
pas fait beau cette semaine des as matin
le disait qu'à lens à aller y avait pas
de problème bon ailleurs dans le royaume
ce que pourrait être un peu moins beau
mais là donc ils rentrent ils vont ils
vont des destinations palais de
buckingham tout à l'heure on les voyait
de dos quand il le fallait mais dont les
voir revenir un peu
sur leurs pas et d'ailleurs bas c'est là
qu'on voyait tout à leur bail est
injustement mario bédard et on les
retrouve à nouveau puisque j'ai envie de
dire mme hayem la parade rentrer chez
elle vous allez la voir apparaître
bientôt vous
même bientôt ça devrait encore prendre
une trentaine de minutes disons à peu
près 1 km de route à parcourir et puis
ça prend un certain temps mais oui on
les attend de retour ici devant
buckingham palace pour le salut royal
les images qu'on garde en mémoire pour
l'instant c'est celle du prince charles
suivi du prince william et de la
princesse anne qui se sont eux aussi
déplacé à cheval pour accompagner cette
parade une tradition qu'est la reine
elizabeth a maintenu pendant très
longtemps elle même lors de suite
oui parce que ce trooping the colour ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui cette parade
militaire c'est peut-être souligner
l'anniversaire
de la reine elisabeth dont le véritable
anniversaire est en avril je vous
rappelle le 21 mai c'est la tradition le
2 juin
donc voilà on attend le retour ici de
cette parade est ce que tout le monde
attend surtout marc andré dans la foule
monstre qui s'est déplacé ici c'est
l'apparition de la reine ya quelques
instants derrière moi on a remplacé le
drapeau sur le toit de ban ki moon bat
kim mcinnes gamme palace paraître pardon
avec l'étendard royal ce qui veut dire
que la reine elle est là les gens donc
applaudissent maintenant après avoir
constaté ce changement parce qu'on
attend de pouvoir la voir au moment où
les forces aériennes royales la raf vont
survoler pour clore ces cérémonies
buckingham et là les gens vont peut-être
est un peu déchiré on trouve regardez
c'est à dire le spectacle aérien il ya
plus de 70 avions militaires qui doivent
y participer ou d'avoir cette apparition
de la reine la reine pour laquelle tout
le monde s'inquiète un peu depuis la
dernière année qui a été
particulièrement difficile pour elle à
96 ans avec la perte de son mari et
aussi la coville d'elles a été beaucoup
moins présent donc c'est ce qu'on veut
aujourd'hui surtout et c'est pour ça
qu'on sait des classes et on comprend
que la scène du balcon j'attendais des
observateurs britanniques là avec des
suppositions et toutes sortes de plats
c'est vraiment un mort d'un point que
luminale dans ce défilé de voir
apparaître la famille c'est le portrait
annuel qu'on va avoir à ce moment là
le portrait de famille le portrait de
famille qui ne comprendra pas le prince
a dit
megan vous savez la famille royale
annoncé que ce ne serait que les membres
actifs de la famille royale qui vont y
être mais oui c'est la photo officielle
c'est le portrait de famille parce que
cette parade elle a été interrompue
pendant dix pendant les deux dernières
années à cause de la situation sanitaire
surtout à cause de la cog vide il ya
deux ans elle avait été annulée l'an
dernier on avait ramené sa des
proportions un peu plus raisonnable mais
c'est une véritable tradition une
tradition qui remonte à plusieurs
siècles c'est est auparavant une
pratique pour pouvoir identifier les
différents régiments dans les batailles
et puis ensuite depuis des décennies
c'est pour souligner l'anniversaire des
monarques la reine elizabeth qui n'en a
jamais manqué une seule depuis son
accession bon alors pendant qu'on voit
tous ces images est con on est con vous
et coach entend également bien des voies
autour de vous pour avoir déjà vu les
lieux je crois où vous travaillez ya
t-il
il ya beaucoup de jeunes là des
britanniques et des visiteurs il ya des
invités mais il ya également on dit que
c'est un milliard de
téléspectateurs pour cet événement la
plume qu'il ya plusieurs journalistes
également qu'ils doivent être corde -la
autour de vous probablement pour
rapporter cet événement là
les gens sont venus de partout dans le
monde et pas seulement les pays du
commonwealth à mai autour de nous il ya
des gens de la presse portugaise la
presse belge la presse française je
croisais des espagnols hier des
allemands aussi énormément médias
américains canadienne présence très très
importante dans la foule aussi on en a
rencontré beaucoup on voit le drapeau
canadien flotter assez fièrement au
premier rang hier on en a rencontré qui
avaient fait le voyage et qui font le
voyage systématiquement pour les grandes
célébrations les couronnements les
mariages les anniversaires comme ça
chaque fois que c'est la fête ici à
londres ces gens là se déplacent pour
pouvoir participer et puis ben oui la
presse elle est descendue en masse et
toute une logistique autour du travail
qu'on peut faire avec des ondes qui sont
réservés en exclusivité à certains
médias et ça demande des mois et des
mois de préparation pour les équipes pas
pour moi ma sandrine mais pour tous ceux
qui nous appuient aujourd'hui les
équipes décision étrangère aussi c'est
beaucoup de travail la nuit castro mais
c'est beaucoup de détails beaucoup de
fils
attirer puis à brancher au bon endroit 1
on s'entend au sens temps là dessus bon
ben écoutez jeu on aura peut-être
l'occasion de vous retrouver un petit
peu plus tard dans les minutes
juste avant ou pendant que la famille
apparaîtra comme ça au grand balcon
merci beaucoup derrière
cela profite
pour enchaîner et vous dire que c'est
elle la scène du balcon elle est très
importante parce qu'on dit que c'est
également loos où la famille a paru le
jour de la victoire le vide et on l'a vu
toute la famille sur ce balcon est ce
que c'est à ce moment là que le balcon
est devenu important
non c'était même avant oui le balcon le
balcon même
à la fin de la première guerre mondiale
le roi georges 5 et la reine marie était
sur le balcon c'est cette tradition de
saluer la foule à des occasions bien
spécifique et ya eu pendant un an au
cours des années 80 jusqu'à une
quarantaine de personnes qui étaient sur
le balcon donc là ça voulait dire que
les
les enfants les petits-enfants de la
reine
l'épousé mais avec leurs enfants même
des invités spéciaux vraiment très triés
sur le volet qui était sur le balcon
mais maintenant maintenant de cette fois
ci on l'a bien spécifié que ce serait
seulement les membres actifs de la
famille royale tout affairé trait au
balcon et on sent là encore
un vouloir de modifier un peu qui fait
maintenant il ya la famille on peut dire
la famille royale et la famille de la
reine ce qui est si il faut faire la
distinction quand on parle de la famille
de la reine c'est comme évidemment ses
enfants ses petits-enfants les cousins
cousines mais la famille royale c'est
notre instinct le sait vraiment quelques
ventes son actif qui représente la
couronne donc on tourne l'impression que
c'est vers cette famille royale en
compte en plus d'aller plutôt que la
famille de la reine bouvier sas n'ont
pas été facile au début de l'année
d'avoir à choisir qui allait être sur le
balcon avec elle encore une fois ça a
été un coup de maître du palais et de la
reine des tiens ça va être les membres
actifs ceux qui ont des devoirs de la
famille royale alors tout de suite ça
sent mis de côté 1 jo qui avait des
problèmes délégation aux finances accuse
un règlement hors cours
aux états unis et puis harry et mégane
qui avait choisi et puis de quitter
également leurs fonctions dont ça
devenait très pratique cette décision
est la sensation de prendre un bain le
fait d'avoir
décidé que c'était les membres actifs
russes et si certains que ça ça évite l
eau
de d'avoir à dire d'une façon explicite
on les met de côté mais qu'on se
souvienne lors du jubilé de 2012
l'apparition au balcon n'avait été que
la reine le prince philip le prince
charles son épouse et ses deux fils donc
ça avait été vraiment restreint et là
bien on retourne vers le fait de dire
que c'est l'imam actifs c'est très bien
ça souligne aussi que c'est eux qui ont
dit des devoirs rodez ils font des
actions pour représenter la couronne
alors c'est madame moi c'est bien
correct de souligner leur leur activité
leur travail mais les autres fois
probable que les autres membres de la
famille on voit les voir
demain lors de la cérémonie d'action de
grâces l'eau à la cathédrale saint-paul
l'eau on va voir plus de membres de la
famille mais aujourd'hui c'est plus la
famille active à la première real est
mal actifs
donc parce que vous vous distinguez un
peu pour nous ce qui est du potin et ce
qui est la réalité parce que on voit
toutes sortes d'articles qui nous disent
que le prince charles a très très mal
pris l'entrevue qu'elle joue avait donné
dans lequel il avait nié toutes les
allégations là d'avoir eu
des des relations avec une mineure aux
états unis jefferies il avait traité
d'idiot
les communications bon je les ai lu la
transcription de l'appel téléphonique
donc puis avec avec harry et son frère
le prince william l'héritier là aussi on
parle des accusations de racisme de
mésentente entre les belles soeurs c'est
serré elles sont six étrangers nous
serons livrés rebonds vous savez la
famille royale c'est une famille comme
une autre donc il ya des membres qui
s'entendent bien ensemble il y en
ad'autres s'entendent un peu moins bien
donc la seule différence c'est que ces
familles lors elle est sur la place
publique sa peau toujours été comme ça
c'est seulement depuis je dirais
la fin des années 70 c'est vraiment les
années 80 que l'eau la famille royale et
de vue vraiment alors tous les journaux
et je crois que c'était avec l'arrivée
de diana princesse de galles que leur
tous les auto en parlait d'une façon à
tous les jours que les gens qui avaient
des articles alors c'est ça qui est
difficile pour eux de prendre c'est de
dette sur la place publique pourtant que
tout le monde commence sur leur vie et
là je me tais pas ce qu'on voit la reine
qui sort aux balkans et on va entendre
certaines plates la masia allons-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va donc les différents
militaires les différents groupes la sto
qui est donc fond le défilé on entend
bien le criollo salute si je me trompe
alors raconté ne peut qu'y est à ses
côtés à la reine sur le balcon je ne
sais pas en fait c'est le duc de kent
oui oui
c'est un cousin de la reine mois se
sont créés par et lé duo comme votre
père le roi george 5 mais je crois
qu'ils portent les attraits du coast
swing and de parce que je peux voir les
lycées qui sous sa casquette
du programme amal colonel honoraire de
ce soit du mal
donc pendant ce temps là les ceux qui
sont qui ont défilé en carrosse
les membres de la famille royale bon
allez rejoindre par quelques instants la
reine sur le ballon
[Musique]
que sur twitter malgré la longueur de
parader pollue beaucoup de personnes
sont tombées sans connaissance parce que
c'est inévitable chaque fois qu'une
parade comme seule une personne qui est
soit déshydraté ou qui s'est passé a pas
assez de riz à vannes laval événement
puis manager il ya une faiblesse c'était
surprenant fait par contre pendant qu'on
parle avec madame bédard il y avait
aussi des arrestations de manifestants
qui avaient sauté par dessus la barrière
alors
je suppose c'est un groupe organisé ou
quoi que ce soit mon parle de trop
quatre personnes qui ont été
appréhendées
[Musique]
on n'est pas des soldats de la tête un
peu plus à l'aigre maintenant parce que
là on vient de passer plusieurs heures
dans des chalands de formation qui sont
assez serrés qu'il faut se rappeler il
faut était exactement la bonne place et
puis là on s'envoie finalement la
baraque
une fois que tout ce que les filets vont
être complétés mais l'on peut relaxer un
peu musculaire mano parce que celle ont
quelquefois
on peut certainement dire également que
la reine regarder observer le point dans
la direction et puis on nous disait que
c'est certain qu'elle observe certaines
choses qu'elle reprenait au régiment
qu'elle reconnaît tous ces gros plans et
même quand elle va rencontrer les
officiels qui ont planifié ces envoyés
noyau dur de le redire à ceux ci a été
réussi mais voilà c'était pas mal mais
c'est toujours sur un ton
apparemment très constructif
je t'aime à la famille royale
les membres de familles royales sont mes
aventures d'un ancien bac ayant palace
[Musique]
d
que je vois si alerte
la fondation agir soir qu'elle a publiés
là également dit lequel fallait voir la
nation l'avenir avec avec confiance et
puis avec enthousiasme et le remercier
tous ceux qui ont participé à
l'organisation de ces de ces festivités
également par la disait que tout le
monde a profité en pour vous pour forger
de nouveaux souvenirs heureux
enfin quand l'allusion à 39 45 quand on
est sorti de la guerre et que les l'état
est aigri et que ceux devenus bien bien
mieux bien bien
plus agréable de vie a eu dix jours
meilleurs on va dire après la deuxième
guerre mais il faut dire qu'on a quand
même les des vapeurs de ses souvenirs là
le suspense en ukraine passerelle ça
ressemble quasiment la garde civile qui
avait
en espagne au tout début laval à la
déclaration de la deuxième guerre
mondiale s est par dax allemand ce qui
est ressorti de ça c'était les allemands
qui testé beaucoup le système d'âmes en
utilisant le front espagnol alors c'est
presque
quand on lit les nouvelles pendant un an
on célèbre le diable on célèbre le
stinger célèbres tels systèmes d'armes
mais à la fin il ya pas grand chose qui
est dit à propos des négociations puis
des discussions diplomatiques
oh
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
m
combien doit gaston est ce que c'était
la relève de la garde
c'est effectivement c'était les sergents
de garn qui est en train de passer les
consignes pour s'assurer qu'il ya aucun
problème non parce qu'en fait il ya
peut-être des personnes qui qui vont
devoir pas un peu de repos avant de
reprendre le poste de garde alors tout
ça se fait très rapidement et puis on
voit aussi on a vu le porte étendard de
repos
là le matin j'ai un vrai choix du magnat
texan à l'aise pour malo pour les mettre
en sécurité
la reine s'est retirée également du
balcon les vues savait plus alerte que
son cousin nourrissant
de chambre à la wii s'est tenue à pic
s'est accroché à la porte bon alors on
la reverra dans quelques instants
avec le reste de la famille
apparaître au balcon
[Musique]
déni
[Applaudissements]
ah ah ah
[Musique]
pas
j'étais là
[Musique]
on
connaît pas les
citer place justement
angers progrès vais parce que je
regardais mes papiers un peu de l'ordre
de cette cérémonie puis on n'attendait
pas l'arrêt menace forme alors des
choses qui ont très planifiée des
surprises qui sont également très
planifiée alors à betfair de vue la
reine et son cousin le duc de kent
[Musique]
elle doit apparaître comme ceux au
balcon et salué les militaires qui
rentre dans les baraques qui se retire
chaque côté à green power d'un côté puis
le parc st james de l'autre alors
on retourne opposition peut-être pour l
accès un peu après oui parce que la
seule chose qui va se dérouler mascella
lagarde
normal la peau kenyan palais
au niveau des manoeuvres militaires et
puis on a toujours d'atteindre
finalement pas ce qu'on appelait le
vol de la
suisse est un petit peu plus tard
les gardes les gardes
comme ça autour du palais
les canadiens sont invités à l'occasion
d'aller faire un tour
une portion oui bah en fait c'est une
tradition qu'on a inauguré durant la
deuxième guerre mondiale - leva royal
22e régiment avait fait la garde
donc il n'ya pas lasser il a évidemment
de sa part à beaucoup de pratiques pour
s'assurer qu'on honore le même standard
que lagarde qui s'y déroulent
normalement et puis lors du les
festivités entourant le 100e
anniversaire du royal 22e humain on
avait proposé justement de refaire cet
épisode le pire cet effet dans le cadre
de sorts par la suite une fois que tout
a été complétée la reine s'est présentée
et nu a remercié les soldats dans un
français impeccable angoissant
[Musique]
alors qu'on voit la faute de tous ceux
qui ont assisté aux défilés aux parades
aux manoeuvres
redescendre le mal est allé vers
buckingham palace on se prépare
également pour les salles de canon canon
un autre moment symbolique dans cette
cérémonie
m
lundi des images du quartier regardez
parc st james à votre gauche et à
l'arrière c'est
green park d'ailleurs kanata gates se
trouve d'un green park est juste
probablement à peu près à la hauteur du
palais de buckingham sur la droite le
canada où je suis totalement abandonnée
et
à l'europa
quand même assez impressionnant de voir
tout le monde qui se trouve là
voilà des images je pense qu'on est là
on est à l'autre bout du monde le palais
se trouve complètement l'autre bouche
qu'on vous montre là c'est une folle
aussi considérable qui d'ailleurs doit
se préparer à descendre le mar pour
aller bon
voir la scène du palace et le coin de
trafalgar square effectivement
[Musique]
il c
mais
[Musique]
je vous l'indiquais c'est ça la foule
commence à remplir nos mains
ça semble être beaucoup les gens qui
étaient à la cérémonie officielle mais
il ya des gens qui étaient pas éviter
qu'on porte du billet qui sont juste de
l'autre côté sans doute d'être tué les
gardes d'ailleurs parce que je suis plus
combien de dizaines de gardes qui ont
passé toutes les cérémonies comme ça de
bouées et mieux observe et on nous dit
ils ont véritablement un rôle de
surveillance parce que s'il ya quelque
chose on dit à la police mais les
bobbies oui on leur signale aux quelque
chose ici c'est les policiers londoniens
qui intervient il faut que ça soit
effectivement très très étroits comme
surveillance parce que il ya quand même
beaucoup de
choses qui se passe à l'échelle
planétaire
et puis il ya quand même possibilité
toujours de voix des attentats
terroristes
on ne pouvait qu chauds souvent ici au
canada mais regarde bretagne ça toujours
été
kezman je dirais pas un événement
quotidienne pendant longtemps j'ai quand
même des des anecdotes là dessus lorsque
je suivais un coup avec des aussi
britanniques et six au canada et trouvé
ça extrêmement plaisant de voix qu'ils
avaient peur qu'ils n'étaient pas
obligés de revoir en dessous de leurs
votes rabaisser le podium planté
les jours tous les matins lorsque il
alors et puis il y avait quand même
aussi des anecdotes un peu plus
amoureuse c'est que étant donné les
attentes qui sablent cible est limitée
britannique à londres on avait ordonné
justement ou aux officiers personnel qui
travaillait au ministère de la défense
de se présenter en civil alors ils ont
tous acheté le même type de be
ce qui est devenu un uniforme ce n'est
presque loufoque de voix que 4,6 et
qu'ils avaient toutes le même des femmes
le même uniforme civile évidemment
alors là c'est le caractère militaire va
s'estomper un peu à partir de maintenant
on attend ce soir des festivités les
pavillons se remplir tout le monde tout
le monde est en congé qu'on veut on veut
profiter de son mandat lui demande
oui
mais c'est aussi ça
les gens passent l'été c'est aussi
bon souligne le jubilé de la reine
on veut aussi montrer que la vie rapin
et pendant une ou deux un extrêmement
difficile qui lors les gens ont le coeur
à la fête
le comics pour les compagnies ce genre
d'événement lors c'est c'est toujours
suivi avec beaucoup de plaisir il ya
énormément
de festivités qui sont organisées
pendant ces quatre jours à travers tout
le royaume uni on parle de plus de 3000
activités dans toutes les villes les
villages on fait les il va avoir des
liens des parts et de rue les gens se
regroupent vers la rue tout le monde n'y
apporte
100 places et
on mange ensemble on fait on chante on
danse alors tout est occasion pour wii
on célèbre doublé de l'art est médecin
c'est comme sont dit on la vie reprend
on se retrouve on reprend nos bonnes
habitudes des ensembles de ce mois ci né
et je pense que c'est ça qui va être
aussi un des faits marquants c'est que
les gens se retrouvent ensemble et ne
sont plus isolés par le fameux de m
c'est également une journée où il se
distingue les britanniques parce que
j'étais là 2002 à l'autre jubilé prenez
jamais dire jamais mais pourquoi
pourquoi c'est important pourquoi aussi
vous si vous célébrez en corse on avait
dit en termes très clairs mais parce que
nous là c'est notre tour eiffel c'est
ses notes 4 juillet c'est comme ça qu'on
se distinguent bon
du sud - des italiens des français c'est
nous c'est la monarchie peu importe
qu'ils sont qui est là
c'est c'est notre carte de visite
finalement
oui la famille royale pour plusieurs
dans le technique ces démarches c'est
leur famille c'est ce qui se passe ça se
passe dans leur famille et
tout le monde est content d'eux on fête
l'anniversaire de laguiole de la famille
donc tout le monde il participe le mans
les joyeux et c'est ça c'est cet esprit
famille leur tee
qui a toujours été très présent chez les
britanniques la famille royale c'est
vraiment oui on l'a beaucoup
suivi dénigrer avec tous les scandales
qui ont eu ces dernières années mais
malgré tout il ya eu un fonds qui est la
femme et c'est cette unité la haye est
extrêmement important sa famille royale
c'est à nous c'est notre famille et on
veut célébrer
le laguiole de de la famille et on en
profite au maximum et il est de loin
celle qui est la plus aimée le plus
apprécié de la famille royale parce que
bon on garde encore il y avait des
sondages réalisés auprès des jeunes
britanniques dans les dix derniers jours
les dernières semaines elle a un très
bon score par contre
oui excusez elle a presque toujours plus
avec cela c'est sûr que ou d'extérieur
dans les années 50 60 ou où sa cote
d'amour si je puis dire au bc mai mais
surtout maintenant elle est toujours à
la tête
du palmarès des membres de la famille
royale est bon c'est certain que il ya
quelques membres de la famille sont
leurs propres est vraiment très très
basses même sous zéro mais il reste qu
on se rend compte que la cote du prince
charles romo doucement surtout
maintenant depuis quelques temps le fait
qu'ils qui participent de plus en plus à
des cérémonies officielles en
remplacement de la reine se cèdent
à changer l'opinion des gens est de plus
en plus il y en a d'autres qui disent
que oui finalement je crois que lorsque
charles sirois il va être un bon voir ce
qui n'était pas le folio fait 10 15 ans
et plus maintenant doucement sac
autrement et
c'est c'est évident le fait que bon oeil
aux verts le le parlement il ya peu de
temps maintenant il fait plusieurs
représentations
à l'extérieur du pays des visites
officielles il est venu ici au canada il
va aller guetter en roumanie ya très peu
de temps donc tous au fait que doucement
sa cote remonter évidemment le prince
william lui aussi une copte assez forte
mais lui il répond plus à la génération
y il va avoir 40 ans dans quelques
semaines donc c'est sûr que il
représente la jeune génération et avec
d'autres idées aussi à peut-être encore
plus moderne que son père alors la jeune
génération compte beaucoup dans l'avenir
sur le prince william pour l'enfer
poursuivre sont traditionnellement
maintenant y apporter encore plus de ma
dernière mais il ya bien des jeunes qui
disait également tout cet argent pour
c'est à peu près c'est pas 22 millions
de livres jeux queue leu leu le trésor
britannique dépenses pour ces
célébrations là est ce que ça pourrait
être mis pour est ce que ça pourrait
être mis ailleurs là où il ya des
besoins des crises d'inflation il ya ce
débat-là également chez les plus jeunes
britanniques baver les ceux qui sont du
même âge que le prince où des abonnés
d'y faire allusion pour pas faire
abstraction sera non plus la sas ainsi
la présence des mots alors oui c'est
très plaisant mais il reste que oui on a
peut-être on dépense peut-être 22
millions de livres pour coller les
quatre jours ces événements alors mais
combien de revenus tout ça apporte aussi
prenez tous les touristes qui sont là
tous les touristes et les chante hôtels
ça ne s'arrête pas juste les quatre
jours sa visite sanaa profite pour
passer une semaine deux semaines en
angleterre donc c'est des revenus qui
viennent dans les coffres imaginez jeu
savant des souvenirs sont aussi c'est
une industrie qui est respectueuse parce
que tout le monde leur apporte quelque
chose alors c'est certain que il ya des
dépenses qui sortent d'une poche mais de
le coter y aussi beaucoup de revenus
kiki rang et je crois que c'est aussi
une question que dans des périodes comme
celle que nous vivons présentement
autant aller deux années de la pandémie
que les troubles qui se passe sur le
continent européen
les gens ont besoin d'avoir des des
cérémonies de célébration de cette
nature là pour continuer à leur donner
l'espoir que les choses sont en période
de changement et qu'on va retrouver
plus une stabilité à plusieurs niveaux
ils sont aussi cessé pour le moral des
gens c'est important tantôt on disait
les fanfares militaires sur les les
champs de bataille était là pour aider
le moral des troupes et les sept
agresseurs d'enfants le jul sert aussi à
ça a aidé au moral des gens a à dire
mais
tout va bien tout revient comme avant et
puis profitant aux enceintes ont
ensemble
mais c'est sûr folio dire des gens ceux
qui sans franck lamanna privé ou qui
sont plus ou moins différents vont
pouvoir le forte que ça coûte cher
plutôt que le côté que ça rapporte une
autre façon
alors d'ici quelques minutes on s'étend
la scène du balcon on attend toujours
également la salve de canon
commémorative également on on les voit
ils sont en place on les voit au moins
s'activer au moins trois ou quatre fois
qu'on voit les artificiers s'avancer ce
recul et prendre différentes positions
alors on est on est à l'affût de ce
moment la
question j'en profite pour vous demander
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça va
représenter ou qu'est ce que ça
représente comme ça parce qu'on alors on
nous dit que c'est un instant à l'autre
on voit les écouter puis ensuite on
m
[Applaudissements]
alors gaston on va revenir donc c'est
aux salves de canon si on comprend bien
il y aura
plusieurs dizaines de coups de canon
qu'est ce que ça représente dans une
cérémonie comme aujourd'hui cette
démonstration de monstration de france
seulement parce que cela retire il s'est
toujours été des reines du champ de
bataille alors c'est sûr que c'est là
leur moment de gloire si on peut dire
pour ce genre d'événement parce que
c'est ni plus ni moins aussi que leur
façon souligné la leur drapeau un jour
tu avais fait ce que leurs drapeaux
alimentation les canons
il va voir 41 coups de canon au winter
et 60 de canon qui vont être tirés de la
tour dont l'ombre
de la tour de l'ombre oui bon et pas le
jeu de la question est-ce qu'une
signification au nombre de coups de
canon comme nous vous évoquez ces
chiffres
oui il ya une signification c'est ce par
rapport au nombre
certains noms mais pour le souverain
ensuite notre vue que ce son
anniversaire alors c'est le cumul de
tous aisée ces couleurs qui font que ce
soit 41 ou 60 et 2
regardez maintenant comment la foule
s'est amassée autour du mode va de la
reine victoria va lier tous ces gens là
sont tous prêts est ce qu'on a compris
tout est rempli on va encore avancer un
peu plus tard aussi là
auront l'occasion d'accrocher les les
portes
à l'extérieur des documents d'époque
rien pour y voir pour voir les vêtements
là probablement que la reine va pouvoir
sortir aussi une fois que le
développement de la foule devrait
compléter new way est ce qu'elle va
certainement gagner pour se lever la
foule
un pur ouais je crois qu'on voyait le
prince charles aussi qui était
donc voilà alors
[Applaudissements]
c'est sans tarder mais crise et que
justement le défilé aérien on va
commencer d'une minute à l'autre les
observateurs ont toujours observer le
comportement l'un des plus jeunes
pourront à quel point il est
enthousiaste de ma passage des des
différents appareils de la aurions un
fausse
les sardes pour appeler injustement le
passé militaire de quelques membres de
la famille royale
lastminute sorbonne cisco a cédé 4
et des mâles
les hélicoptères de chasse anti sous
marine
pour 4 je crois c'est un célibataire de
reconnaissance
ne relève pas mal plus gros point fort
c'est le même type d'hélicoptère
condamne à embarquer sur les bateaux
or il ya quand même des capteurs date à
coup sûr
apache ah-64
parce que je peux voir
les crétins qui étaient les capteurs
répartis normalement
qui
j'essaie de me rappeler
la française est docteur là parce qu'ils
étaient il faisait de la lutte anti sous
marine mais aussi
par celui qui a la main comme ça au pyla
il s'active séduit le qui a écrit
c'était moi ya pas si longtemps quand il
est apparu pour la première fois comme
ça sur le balcon alors le petit a grandi
on voit des thunes okotie
l'hélicoptère de transport
très utile très impressionné aussi
comporter plus de 30 personnes la mort
soulever 18h22 temps nous si c'est
très puissant
très impressionnant dans ciel de londres
devant ces appareils de ces éléments
les trois enfants du second rôle à
lacets deuxième guerre mondiale tout à
fait
l'esprit de chaque côté peut-être
que c'était le bon bassiste alain casas
et sur
wii 2 voire 3 spitfire et dans ce que
vous avez vu là c'était l'autre je sais
se déterminer dès le week end également
way peut-être un week-end à droite être
objectivement
alors bien les voir oui alors je lui
envoie c'est un week-end tous les autres
se disputent faire
face il aurait mérité la forme la forme
vue de profil est assez singulière
quoique c'est qu'on peut avant le repas
[Rires]
telle voie des avions plus modernes
maintenant qui va devrait se profile à
l'horizon alors sur scène les avions
d'entraînement sont en souffrance à
sable de tout cas
sur cc 130 en fait la version
j je crois
à plusieurs bateaux et un avion
extrêmement utile
dans lequel j'ai passé plusieurs heures
de ma vie on en a transporté les casiers
du matériel apple wind à ce type d'avion
mais les pilotes des pilotes ne m'aimait
pas parce qu'il ne sait pas de barclays
une fois au sol il m'a envoyé dans l'air
mais c'est sans toit en toit
car même en avion qui datent
conception dans les années 50 puis
s'est amélioré au fil du temps
des
mets moteur turbo avec impuissance et le
c17
avec le a4 ça aura 400 sein d'airbus
l'avion transporte aussi à
4-4 matin et puis une capacité beaucoup
supérieur au centre en mai
il ya aussi le 6 17 dont le canada a
fait l'acquisition non je crois c'est
sous cet appareil de ce type là ça va
des services incroyable surtout ball
ravitaillement et alliende lorsqu'on est
à l'extérieur
sans s'offre à son sens d'un avion est
un avion de ligne n'est le poséidon
sommes opposés dans quoique joie paul
loridant il a laissé se pourrait que ce
soit un rêve est arrivé arriva c'est un
avion de renseignement
fatima des avions qui avaient née
particulier il ya des fin à leur
programme le match ça doit être lui
qu'elle radars et puis là on a des
chasseurs qui survole maintenant avec un
avion probable max est au ravitaillement
aérien
là dans les avions comme thème j'avoue
que leur camouflage noter c'est bon
parce qu'ils font des 25es les typhons
sont relativement faciles
à ce sont les avions purement
britanniques typhon et puis les f 35
ils ont fait l'acquisition
s'élève 35 ans voilà justement
les lions assez spectaculaire si on
garde toutes les capacités
j'ai appris énormément atteindre leur
moto pour les comptes
c'est ça ressemble des orques les
raisons
du t2 oui c'est des avions
d'entraînement
ils sont particulièrement
flexible - cd rock c'est ça
même averti le tout du spectacle
approche
en dix ans
[Applaudissements]
lien en formation comme ça c'est pas
toujours facile
voilà soixante dix
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est des tarifs se serait rapproché
l'équipe démonstration
[Musique]
là
si ce n'est que je pense
[Applaudissements]
sont tous les avions qui ont marqué la
carrière de la reine ou tellement
j'en profite pour aller tout de suite
voir marie-eve bédard qui est à
proximité justement de cette scène et
qui dans cette foule qui semble bien
l'apprécier
evènement et semble bien goûter le
moment en arrière
ou un retraité du spectacle ce spectacle
aérien et puis l'apparition de la reine
entourée de la famille royale sur le
balcon c'est ce que tout le monde qui
s'est déplacé aujourd'hui espérer voir
marc andré et la reine a fait non pas
une mais deux apparitions un peu plus
tôt elle est venue saluer les gardes
irlandais qui ont défilé comme elle n'a
pas pu se rendre pour le salut royal
pour la première fois depuis le début de
son règne elle est sortie un peu plus
tôt avec le duc de kent sur le balcon et
là maintenant ayez toujours entouré vous
aurez du mal à le voir derrière moi
c'est quand même un peu loin est
toujours entouré des membres actifs de
la famille royale lors qu'istres qui a
défilé aujourd'hui ils étaient plus de
400 musiciens entonné god save the queen
et puis on entend la fouille qui
applaudit toujours cette apparition la
reine elizabeth qui célèbre 70 ans de
règne
platine mais aussi son 85e anniversaire
aujourd'hui c'est le début des
célébrations qui maintenant vont se
poursuivre sur les quatre prochains
jours un peu partout au pays mais
surtout ici à londres une foule monstre
on n'a toujours pas les évaluations des
policiers de la ville mais juste pour
vous donner une idée il y avait trois
millions de personnes qui s'étaient
déplacées au moment de son couronnement
hélas le mal il est bon deal très tôt ce
matin très difficile de circuler aux
abords de tous les sites où il ya eu ce
défilé aujourd'hui tout son
extraordinaire faisait pas été témoin de
tout à l'heure on nous évoque peut-être
qu'il y avait des gens qui avaient tenté
de sauter des barricades ou des
barrières mais tout semble se dérouler
relativement dans l'ordre dans
l'atmosphère festive
l'atmosphère est relativement bon enfant
il ya eu un incident tout au début de la
parade quand les soldats et les chevaux
prenait place il ya un groupe de cinq
hommes qui ont tenté d'intercepter leur
route ils se sont précipités pour
traverser la route du mal qui était
fermée au public à ce moment-là il
portait des couronnes dorées et des
signes c'est un groupe d'activistes
animalier rébellion animal qui se disent
solidaires d'extinction rébellion qui
protestaient l'industrie laitière les
policiers ont procédé très rapidement
l'arrestation des cinq personnes et puis
tout a pu se dérouler dans le bon ordre
par la suite très bien merci beaucoup
marie-eve à plus tard
on va
alors estelle on a eu droit donc à
quelques surprises que vous allez
peut-être archives est maintenant là
pour ce 70e anniversaire
oui évidemment de la deuxième mais la
première apparition de la reine
s'était évidemment une surprise etc
c'est excellent qu'elle a pu saluer
quand même les troupes qui défilaient et
ensuite de voir
la voie avec
toute la famille sur le balcon et on
sentait très bien son enthousiasme son
plaisir d'être là bon elle était appuyée
sur sa canne mais s'est fait très
discret et
je crois que
la folie qui s'est déplacé en fort ici
de la voir aujourd'hui et je crois que
les gens commencent à s'habituer à ce
que sa présence va être plus rares dans
des événements de cette nature mais que
ce qu'elle vaut choisir d'assister on
voit est encore plus
significatif pour tout le monde ça va
être vraiment alors spécial lorsqu'elle
voyait son dernier mot aussi sur toute
la
planification qu'un événement comme je
la concertation d'abord de l'effort
militaire ensuite le contrôle des foules
c'est tout un événement qu'on vient voir
pourrais absolument puis il ya bien des
des organisations qui sont appliquées
l'adami damas la police par pour prendre
le contrôle des folies à l'installation
des barricades et l'installation des
sièges à toute la logistique derrière
tout ça il ya aussi des endroits pour
disperser les troupes une fois que la
cérémonie est terminée alors tout ça ne
doit être prise en compte et toujours
étant donné les incidents se sont déjà
déroulées à londres toujours dans une
perspective d'assurer la sécurité autant
d'aider des personnes qui viennent voir
le spectacle que les militaires
eux-mêmes
bombe a coûté il m'a juste à vous
remercier gaston merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous éclairer sur la valeur de
certains des gestes qu'on a vu
c'est elle ben on va se donner
rendez-vous nous demain puisqu'il ya une
messe très important pour la chef de
l'église anglicane un d'avoir une image
comme ça pour célébrer un jubilé aussi
important
donc à demain donc à compter de 6 heures
marc laurendeau sera avec nous également
demain pour commenter ce moment qui se
déroulera toujours allons donc on vous
vous retrouvez demain à compter de
6 heures merci d'avoir établi
[Musique]